hi there Steve Kaufman here today I'm
back in Vancouver after having attended
the long Fest the festival of languages
in Montreal remember and today by the
way I'm going to talk about
comprehensible input as the key driver
of language acquisition a major theme at
the conference in Montreal but remember
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe we were lucky we were very
fortunate to have in montreal stephen
krashen who has written widely on the
subject of language language acquisition
and stresses that there is only one way
in which we acquire language and that is
through comprehensible input messages
that are meaningful to us he went so far
as to say that the the content that we
use should be compelling and so there
was his conference was very interesting
there was there were other speakers
presenters who dealt with this theme for
example Paul Doucet who is a teacher in
New York state of belief of languages
who is a wonderful Pali God himself and
he also stressed the importance of
comprehensible input ci as it's referred
to and how this revolution in language
learning and language instruction is
still largely a concept that people pay
lip service to whereas in schools kids
are primarily taught through the old
grammar instruction you know system and
he explains some of the difficulties in
introducing sort of CI comprehensible
input based instruction he referred to
tt-rs
teaching proficiency through reading and
storytelling which is a popular
technique that is gaining in popularity
these are all things that you can google
for TP RS you can google for stephen
krashen comprehensible input and so
forth but today i want to talk about it
from the perspective of me the learner
so people often say comprehensible input
but when you're starting in the language
you don't understand anything now the
theory is if you read material that is
always a little bit difficult for you
perhaps initially you have a very short
lesson with a vocabulary list or
something
and gradually you you deal with material
that has a small number of new words and
gradually by reading extensively and by
listening you will eventually acquire
the language it isn't quite that simple
in reality because if you are constantly
dealing with material that has only a
few unknown words you will take forever
to learn the language so you have to in
least in my experience I try to speed
things up so I will of course in the old
days I would deal with with readers
where there was a vocabulary list the
difficulty is if you review a vocabulary
list before reading something
essentially you don't remember much in
fact there is research that shows if two
groups of students one group knows what
the story is about has read it in
English or something and the other group
is given a vocabulary list it's the
first group those who are familiar with
the subject matter that will understand
more reviewing a vocabulary list ahead
of reading something has very little
impact on our comprehension
so I've always said the sort of a major
revolution has been reading online or on
your iPad with access to an online
dictionary you can quickly look
something up it doesn't tell you the
full meaning of the word it may even
give you a slightly erroneous sense of
what the word means but in most cases it
allows you to get through the content
and of course if you're on link you can
save that for later review and of course
the word on your screen changes color
which is a form of reminder helping you
notice the fact that this is a word that
you've seen so the use of modern
technology enables us to access material
with a higher percentage of unknown
words it needn't be just 5% unknown
words I'm very happy with material of
this 10 or 15 percent unknown
once heard up to 30 or 40% it becomes
difficult so obviously when you start
though it's all unknown so this is
another important point to me as a
language learner you know I know in my
presentation I talked about the very
steep start to language learning I
called it the blade of the ups to upside
down hockey stick where you are
struggling to kind of get a grip of the
language you have a sense of
satisfaction that you're able to make
some sense of it you're starting to hear
where words and the new words begin and
you're struggling and then after that
there's this long period of acquiring
all the words you need to get to some
form of comfortable ability in the
language call it fluency call it B - so
during this first period the content
that you are using the input material
can't be that compelling you know on its
own it's not something that you will
read in your own language so this is
important to remember I am compelled to
work on my Greek or my Hebrew many
stories not because they are so
tremendously interesting but because I
am compelled to discover this language
so my color tolerance for content that
is not maybe intrinsically so
interesting my tolerance for that is
higher and so I work my way through
these the other thing I do and this is
an important point I read and listen
many many times mark and I my son Mark
who is the chief operating officer at
link and co-founder with me he showed
what he did in his account in both
Spanish and Italian and you know I think
you can basically all of the audio from
the lessons you can move it to a
playlist so that you can listen to it
and the playlist tracks how many times
you listen and I saw that mark had been
listening to his Spanish lessons 40 50
times and I hadn't really looked at it
but then I checked my own playlist in
Greek and sure enough I've been
listening to those many stories 50 40 35
times and so obviously the 30th time you
listen it's no longer come
you're not you know curious to know how
it ends but we are compelled at least I
am I am compelled because I want to get
a better handle on I want to understand
it better I want to go over these words
again I have saved certain phrases that
I want to get ahead a lot so I am
motivated by my desire to get past that
very steep beginning in the language get
to a level where I don't have to listen
30 times where I can access material
that is interesting of itself it could
be the history of the country or some
news article so during that period of
course you have to read and listen many
many times and every time I listen again
I noticed something else I notice a turn
of phrase or a structure or something
that I hadn't noticed before so
compelling input comprehensible input I
think can mean different things at
different stages in your learning and I
think at an initial stage you are able
using online dictionaries or a system
like link to plow your way through
material that might have 15 20 percent
unknown words in it course initially
it's 100 percent and as you progress you
listen less and less often to the same
material you're moving more quickly on
the new material and and I think in this
issue of repeating verses going to new
material I always say don't don't I
don't wait until I have totally aced
something before I move on in fact very
often I move on to the next story in the
next dirty story in the next story
and then I go back again to the
beginning because the brain as I often
quote manfred spitzer the great german
neuroscientist
who said that the brain requires
repetition and novelty so you can repeat
and repeat but after a while the
repetition isn't doing anything so you
got to give the brain something new but
then you can go back and there's nothing
more enjoyable than going back to
something that was very difficult two
months earlier and now has become easier
so comprehensible input input is what
drives our language acquisition that's
not to say that we don't occasion
further grammar or have a teacher give
us a little explanation again as Paul
Doucet said in his presentation if an
issue of grammar comes up in a TP RS
classroom
he says you get this five second spot of
grammar and then you go back to the
story to the input and and the
expectation is not that this explanation
of grammar should then be remembered and
known and mastered it simply helps you
get through the story and in this way
the story the content is gradually
helping your brain get accustomed to the
language get accustomed to the
structures in the language acquire the
vocabulary of the language so
comprehensible input compelling input
compelling for different reasons at
different stages that's what drives
language learning and so there you have
it I look forward to your comments and
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]